Sal Khan's response to the crisis in
education is khanacademy.org a site that
lists at vast and growing collection of
his YouTube video lessons in math
physics chemistry biology and economics
in this conversation with interviews
with innovators host Jon Udell he
discusses his teaching philosophies and
methods and explains why he abandoned a
career in financial services to become a
new kind of teacher from IT
conversations
hi and welcome to IT conversations I'm
Phil went Li the executive producer
today I'm happy to bring you another
program from Jon Udell
interviews with innovators this program
is made possible by microsoft's channel
9 and channel 10 our audio files are
delivered by limelight networks the high
performance content delivery network for
digital media the conversations network
is a 501c3 nonprofit and we need your
help for a tax-deductible donation of as
little as 5 dollars per month you can
support this channel and the rest of the
conversations network so please visit
conversations network org to become a
member and help us continue to bring our
programs to the world for free and now
here's Jon Udell I saw something online
the other evening that reminded me of
what you're doing in an interesting way
so it might be a fun place to start
there's an artist in Los Angeles named
Richard Antrim and somewhere around 2000
or 2001 he got pissed off about the fact
that there's this freeway intersection
in Los Angeles that's very poorly
labeled and in particular there is a key
missing piece of information which was a
place where there should have been a
sign that said North 5 just it just
wasn't there and so he went and made a
North 5 sign to the highway departments
specifications then he made himself a
uniform and then he got up on a ladder
and he went out and he installed the
thing and he he calls this gorilla
public service as in gorilla the freedom
fighter not gorilla the great ape and
you know since then as far as I know
it's still up and you know probably
millions of people have have benefited
from that and it just reminded me of
what you're doing in a way in the realm
of Education which is sort of looking at
a situation and thinking you know what
I'm just gonna go do something about
that and and and you know thanks to the
technology of the internet I can be a
super empowered individual and there
really is essentially no limit to how
far that can scale out and how many
people I can help
it's really a wonderful thing so you
know tell us about the about the kind of
Kadim II yeah so I it's most known for
the roughly 1200 videos on YouTube it's
it's being mirrored other places and
other people are distributing it offline
but YouTube's
really the main way that people access
to videos and it really started off very
organically I was I was helping out
cousins and family members and and I
just and it seemed to be working well I
was tutoring them remotely I was in
Boston they were I'm in in Northern
California now but they were in New
Orleans and and when I was doing this
one-on-one tutoring with them it seemed
to be very effective and I just kept
thinking how could I make it scale and
yeah and there's actually a software
piece and I started working on at first
and and a buddy of mine said hey why
don't you put some some videos in the
software and and by the time I got over
the idea that I didn't think of it I I
started recording a couple of videos and
the videos are what what what really
took off I think it's just the low
barrier for people to use it even my own
cousin's say that I'm I'm better on
YouTube than I am live pause and repeat
me and they don't feel like the videos
judging them the way so so yeah and I I
put it out there and and you know I
think as a fellow software engineer you
can appreciate how fun it is when people
actually use something you've built and
and when I just put it out there you
know I've written hundreds of pieces of
software that absolutely no one uses
just a couple of YouTube videos out
there and within a day at least when I
started 20 or 30 people were using them
and some subset of them would write a
note saying hey I got an a on my algebra
exam because of this or you know I feel
prepared to go back to college next year
or some of them were you know I was
gonna drop out until I saw something
like this and so you just get one note
like that you're like wow this is more
impact than I've ever had doing anything
else so I just kept making the videos
and the traffic just kept picking up
organically and it started to be become
pretty clear that there was a need being
addressed and so you've actually decided
to try to reconfigure your life where
you have reconfigured your life around
this away from I guess most recently
financial services yeah I was when I
started doing this I was originally
tutoring my cousin Nadia in New Orleans
they they just visited me in Boston
after my wedding
was a hedge fund analyst in Boston and
and I was a hedge fund analyst until
this past September and to larger even
while I was while my day job was was in
in finance I had already reconfigured my
life around this I was pretty much every
every waking moment where I felt that my
wife wouldn't feel that I was being
completely delinquent of my family
duties I would sneak away and start
doing YouTube videos or I'd also work on
the software that would give people
exercises to do and so I could track
what they were doing and so it was
really I've kind of just come to terms
with the fact that this is this is what
I what I think I should be doing all the
time so in September I quit my job and
and I've been doing it full-time and and
I haven't looked back since although I'm
although my bank account is slowly
depleting so hopefully I'll figure out a
way to to make that at least not deplete
I am certain that you will and and I
hope that people who will be listening
to this can maybe help with that because
this is clearly what you should be
spending your time doing and I think
you've written somewhere that you you
you realized this was the way that you
could have the most leverage and do the
most good and have the most fun and oh
yeah if you just think about it's
actually it's my it's such a simple
thing you know I could do a video on you
know the fundamental theorem of calculus
and it might take me you know maybe is
something I knew before I even started
doing this I would have to prepare much
and it takes me 10 or 20 minutes to do
the video and then I put it up there and
literally millions of people for as long
as the internet exists can use that
video and and and my or your
great-grandchildren could use that video
so I mean just just in terms of the
return on time invested or the return on
you know mental capital invested however
you want to view it it's it's mind
boggling yeah well it's it's an
astonishing amount of leverage but this
is also what this also points to is that
you know I was watching a TED talk that
Bill Gates gave recently and in part of
it he was discussing education and you
know from the software business that
there's this meme about there being a
really big difference between an average
software engineer and a great software
engineer and it's not just you know like
twice as good it's you know order of
magnitude too
so at least this is the claimant and he
was making that same argument in the
realm of Education and and that the
Gates Foundation had had been looking
into this and had concluded that it's
the same right that there you know that
there are some teachers who are just way
way better than average and and you know
how can we leverage that and this is I
mean what you're doing is a perfect
illustration of how we could leverage
that but I want to kind of ask you about
you know I mean clearly you're a great
teacher and you've love to do it
but when you know when did you sort of
realize that and and and what is it
about you and how you think and and how
you present things and and how you
communicate you know have you analyzed
what it is that you think is effective
III I've tried to I've obviously I mean
I you know I think about that myself
it's not the idea of putting instruction
on the web and letting people use it
isn't in you and I wasn't the first
person to think of it and so I do
introspect a lot as to why these videos
that seemed to kind of struck a chord
with people and gotten a lot of traction
I think it's a couple of things I mean
just you know you ask about just you
know when did I realize and I think
growing up I was and I think this is
probably true of a lot of people who you
know it's probably true of yourself or a
lot of people who do well in the math
and science is that they they they kind
of go beyond what's going on in the
classroom and they make connections on
their own and if anything they they get
frustrated by what goes on in the
classroom and they see otherwise
intelligent peers memorizing facts and
not really caring about the actual
intuition and because they didn't care
about the intuition in their junior year
when that that same idea pops up in the
senior year it's it it's like they've
never seen it before and and it would it
would boggle my mind it's just you know
you're relabeling the same concept over
and over so I've always had that
frustration I've always been someone
that always liked to ponder what I was
learning as opposed to and sometimes it
was at my detriment because if you know
you'll have a so much time in your day
and you can either do it that what the
teacher tells you to do or you can
ponder and the pondering might pay off
in the long term but the not doing what
the teacher tells you to oh my what will
hurt you in the short term but uh that
that was kind of my frustration of my
education throughout high school and
college I was kind of the guy who
skipped class a lot and just trying to
read a book and then read other books
and talk to my friends about the concept
of
to necessarily going to classes just cuz
I I felt that I was either lost in class
or I was bored in class and it was very
it was maybe you know on a good class I
would maybe there would be ten minutes
where I was actually it was it was
catering to me and and so it was a very
that was also a frustrating experience
and it it really felt like there was a
there must be a better way and so when I
started tutoring my cousin Nadia you
know it I started tutoring her as kind
of a friend or a cousin as opposed to a
teacher and I think I think that tone if
I had to pick one thing that that has
has kind of resonated with people it's
the stone that you know I got a note the
other day on YouTube channel where you
know you teach more like a friend and a
teacher and yeah you can interpret that
in multiple ways but I think that's I
think that's the the core issue that the
tone doesn't turn people off I think
that the next thing is what I touched on
in my own experience is that I I'm
really big on making connections I get a
lot of letters and you can almost sense
the anger from the students where they
communicate that their teachers think
that they're making it easier for the
students by not giving the intuition by
not giving the the depth or making the
connections because they kind of think
that the students just need to learn the
mechanics but I get letter after letter
saying because you get the intuition
because you you give the common sense
why this you know why this is just a
mathematical way of expressing something
that makes a lot of sense it actually
becomes a lot more easy and a lot a lot
more intuitive and and I think if you
combine that with YouTube it used to
limit me to 10 minutes and I've gotten
letters from researchers telling me that
it's been established that nine minutes
is about as long as someone can really
focus and pay attention without kind of
taking a mental break and so so I give
credit to YouTube for that I now can
record a little bit longer than ten
minutes but I think that's a big thing
and I think that the other thing this
was just a complete side effect of me
trying to do it is cheaply as possible
without fancy video equipment is you
don't see my face and I've been told by
a lot of people that that keeps it from
being a distraction and it's actually
makes it very easy for me to make the
videos I don't have to shave or wash my
face just have to make sure yeah I mean
it's so the process the process that you
use is apparently delightfully low-tech
it looks to me or you should say but
to me like you're using tools as simple
as maybe windows paint and and or I
don't know what but it's it's nothing
fancy right no the first when I the the
first time where I decided to make the
videos I said well how can I make a
decent video for my cousin's and I
literally I took Microsoft Paint but
made the background black just cuz I
thought it would look nice like a
chalkboard and I used some shareware
screen capture software it was like you
know a free for 20 days and then you got
to pay twenty dollars after that yeah I
got myself a twenty dollar headset and a
sixty dollar Wacom pen tablet and and
and I started doing it and actually the
the production quality was pretty good
the first I would say four or five
hundred videos were done exactly like
that and you could see if you see some
of the earlier videos yeah now up
created slightly but not really that
much one of the users just sent me a
license to Camtasia I think there's
other things I could use as well that
would do scream chat screen capture
fairly well and and I now use a slightly
better art program that at least you
know it's a little bit sensitive to
pressure on the pen tablet but it's uh
it's still pretty low tech yeah exactly
and well well it's interesting because
when I got started I was actually I look
on Wikipedia I'm the person whose name
is associated with the word screencast
because I got interested in that stuff
seven years ago and actually ran a
little because because I was making
these software demos I'm using Camtasia
and its predecessors and got really
interested in that process and so a
certain point I got to where I was
making really pretty highly produced
kinds of things that were tightly edited
and it would that was interesting you
know to do that process but at a later
point I started to rethink that and I'm
at one at one moment I remember a friend
of mine his name is Chris Gemignani and
he's he's a an analytics and
visualization person and every once in a
while he makes these screencasts to show
people things that he can teach them in
in say Excel and he made one of these
and it was full of stops and starts and
oh you know I didn't mean to do it that
way and
and let's back up and and try another
path and we talked about it afterward
and he he said you know I felt like I
should edit that stuff but then I
realized in a way that if I did then I
wouldn't be giving people their true
insight into the process of how I think
about these things and how my and how I
do these things and so the in fact the
unedited style wound up being better and
I think maybe that's true for you too oh
absolutely I mean that's that's actually
you know that's probably one of the top
three in terms of why I mean it was
really out of laziness initially I was
for my cousin's I was like you know I
don't care what they think I'm doing
this out of my hood so I would put it
out there if I you know I I wouldn't do
the problem before I made the video so
they saw me doing the problems the first
time and every now and then I would go
down one route and and say oh wait maybe
that's not right now would back up a
little bit and that's something frankly
that no one ever sees you don't your
lecture and you're in you're in your
high school trigonometry class they have
done the problem ahead of time or they
have the solution in front of them and
so you just see the finished product you
don't actually see the thought process
and I think to actually see someone
stumble around a little bit who you
respect who you you know you realize
knows what they're doing but still they
stumble around and see kind of the art
of solving a problem I think is is
something you'll never see in a
traditional lecture or textbook and so
that might also imply that you do
relatively less prep then another person
might imagine would be necessary because
because thinking on your feet is part of
the process it's this part yeah now kind
of embraced that idea now that there's
more viewership I almost feel like I
should prepare more and make it more
polished but I I kind of fight that that
that that instinct and I still want to
keep them relatively raw I mean I want
to I want to make them easy to watch but
you really want to I get a lot of
letters people appreciate these you know
I've there's the College Board SAT book
and I did all 400 math problems and I
literally did them in real time so yes
literally like sitting on my shoulder
while I take an SAT exam which is a kind
of it's a you know I don't think a lot
of people will will kind of expose
themselves in that way but and and but I
think it's an incredibly valuable
experience there's no one you never
actually get to see that in real life in
so many ways we never get the
opportunity to look over the shoulder of
a practice
of any discipline and this has been one
of my biggest hopes for the medium of
Internet video as a matter of fact is
that exactly that becomes possible and
you know I've thought a lot about how in
earlier incarnations of human society
that was really the norm you know I mean
when you were living in a tribal or a
village kind of a situation the work
that people did was visible to you right
you just had to look and see what people
were doing it was just out there in the
open and so you know I mean part of
Education was just seeing what people
did and in a funny kind of way I
realized that you know when we got to
this mode where we're all in cubicles
with with keyboards and screens but were
but we're communicating through email
and we're communicating through these
other you know sort of mediated channels
in a way we we actually lose the ability
to watch other people to see how they
work with their tools to see how their
minds work right and and so like we're
capturing that is is a really
interesting possibility for the the
medium of Internet video and you're a
great illustration of that yeah I a
hundred percent agree and I think that
extends even beyond what I'm doing I'm a
I'll say I won't name him because well
the story isn't flattering to his
company but he's kind of used my example
and he does analytics at a company and
he was running some reports and instead
of writing a white paper on on what this
report means or how do you run it and
like like you would traditionally do in
a corporation he told his the CEO of the
company hey you don't have this buddy he
doesn't sing on YouTube using Camtasia
how about I do the same thing instead of
writing a white paper on how to do it
how about I just capture my screen while
I do it and I'll talk out loud and yeah
and you know I thought was a brilliant
idea what better way than the guy who's
kind of writing it to learn from you
know looking over his shoulder how he
does it but but but but she thought it
was silly just cuz I think it's not it's
not how the other corporations do it
I'll do the corporation she worked for
did it but but I think it's going to
happen I think I think a lot of these
short technical papers are going to
become obsolete because people can just
look over someone's shoulder and see how
they do in real time there's a video
that you may have seen by this this guy
Hans Rosling
he he wrote the Gapminder software which
is this pretty incredible data
visualization he's given a couple of TED
talks and and what you realize when you
see him giving one of these
presentations is that you know it's only
partly about the high-quality animated
visualizations which the software can
produce it's also about how he performs
the the presentation around that right
right and so it's the combination of him
you know using the software along with
his voice along with his body in this
case you know to illustrate that that is
incredibly powerful and again and again
it scales and then what I wanted to get
to though was what you know where where
are the limitations still and how can we
address them so you know one thing a
person doesn't get to do is interact
with you it's one way in in the course
of these videos so it's it's it's not
sort of a complete replacement you know
for much or some of what happens in
school it's however a useful complement
and I have it you know read some summing
some indications that people are
beginning to combine your stuff with
classrooms and interactive settings but
what do you think about that yeah you
know when I started this I you know that
was kind of my sense as though well you
know it doesn't have the interactivity
of a live one-on-one session but but you
know I'm kind of come to the conclusion
I don't want to be too grandiose about
its potential but III do think that it
is actually but I mean I think it's it's
hands down better than the professor
sitting in front of a classroom of 300
students and just lecturing of prepared
kind of scripted lecture to them you
know one that's kind of artificial the
it's a 90 minute long thing it's you
know it may not be it's probably not
catering to all of the students some
students are lost some are bored they
might be sleepy you know she's not the
time there's no there's no question
about that and so here you're getting it
when you want it you're getting it in
kind of granular chunks and you can
pause repeat if I say orthogonal and you
don't know what that means you can look
it up on what
you can pause it get up on Wikipedia you
can go look at the other video that I've
done on orthogonality and fill in the
blanks just to review so so I think on a
lot of levels it's you know like my
cousin said I think it's it's uh I'm
better and a lot of lectures would be
better on YouTube than then live I think
the and and then there's also the
opportunity to really tweak it where you
know YouTube gives me data on on where
attention span drops off on my videos
and so if something unusual happens in
one of my videos I can go back to that
point see what happened maybe record
another video if it's if it's because I
throw out a weird concept or I skipped a
step or whatever so there's also exactly
this potential of really tweaking and
eventually where you know and that's why
I want to do the software and I've been
working on the software because I want
to see how people interact with
exercises before and after the video
interaction so you know attention span
is one thing but I also want to see
whether they learned and so you can
imagine a world where you can you make a
video or I make a video we make multiple
versions of the same video and we just
see which one's work best for different
people so the potential there's things
that have never been imagined with
traditional I think you know but the
limitation I think is just that notion
that there's this individual who cares
directly about you so when I first
worked with my cousin's I think that's
that idea of my 12 year old cousin
feeling like her 20 at the time I was 26
year old cousin who you know took time
out of his day to mentor her I think
that's incredibly incredibly valuable
but I think you know frankly that's not
going on in the school system right now
right right now you're lucky if you have
a conversation with your teacher in the
class 30 and it's usually the problem
kids who are having the most time with
the teacher and it's not a positive
interaction yeah I'll tell you a funny
story about some some other educational
videos that I've seen I was um I catch a
lot of this stuff in podcast form and at
one point I was doing I was kind of
auditing a course I'd evolutionary
biology out of I think it was Berkeley
and so I remembered actually something I
had seen in that course a couple of
years before and I wanted to use that
insight in something I was writing on my
blog and so I went back to try to find
it and when I went back to look at it I
wound up doing the video instead of the
Audio like I usually do and my daughter
who was just getting ready to enter
college was looking over my shoulder
while I was playing this video and she
said so did the students just sit there
in a large lecture they do right but
then the other weird thing about that
was that when I finally found that
installment of the course he wasn't as
good at what the what they had done is
they had replaced this semesters version
with the version from two years ago that
I had seen and he'd been better two
years ago right it was like you know he
actually had the more effective version
and so why not just can that and reuse
that and use the class time for you know
supplementary kinds of things or
interactive kinds of things right yeah
from teachers that's exactly they're
starting to assign the videos instead of
reading and homework and then you do
your homework in class and that's where
you really benefit from exam one having
the teacher there but even more having
your peers there exactly exactly yeah so
I think that that will be really
fruitful and something else that I'm
interested in is the notion that you
know you talked about caring about the
intuition and and transmitting the
intuition and and that happens in a
pretty personal way for you and so you
know what we get is this view sort of
through your eyes of how these
intuitions made sense to you which is
great because a lot of times that
doesn't come front and center you know
if we start to get a few more people
like you out there as well and we can
start to triangulate on these things
it'll be even better because you know
ultimately there might be some you know
some other person like you might have a
way of thinking about it that works
better for me absolutely and if I could
access in the context of a particular
you know subject if I could triangulate
and assemble well you know here's Sal's
way of thinking about it here's somebody
else's way of thinking about it right
and you know if I can pull those things
together which really you know just
through sort of tagging things on
unserviceable at hard to let happen in a
pretty loosely coupled way
I think there's I mean you could write
just from people reviewing it or tagging
it you could start to understand what
will respond with different people or
maybe people could use multiple
viewpoints but then if you really do
couple that with you know exercises
where you're we were able to track
everything and do some analytics and you
can do some pretty profound and you know
really scientifically determine what
works for different people right so to
see a little bit more about the the
software that you're you're working on
it what it will do in and where it's
going it already exists on the site I've
actually just had to add to port it to
it App Engine is because it was too many
people were using it I guess it's not a
bad problem until me when you're the
support staff and engineers check but
but it's the idea is very simple it
starts at one plus one equals two it
just generates random problems and you
got a each module is like a concept like
basic addition one plus one equals two
two plus three is equal to five and you
got it get ten in a row once you have
ten in a row on that and that's it
that's a you know something that doesn't
happen in the school system no one
expects you to get ten in a row they
expect you to get 70 percent right and
then you move on but you get ten in a
row and then it's kind of a if you can
imagine a no directed graph have
something called a knowledge map and you
know your basic addition once you get
ten in a row you've then fulfilled the
prerequisites for level 2 addition and
basic subtraction and then those fulfill
the prerequisites and you have this this
know directed graph and right now it
goes up through pretty much all of
algebra 2 and trigonometry my the first
wave of the videos on YouTube go well
beyond that they go you know into
college level math and physics and
chemistry but the software the idea is
what to have it at least cover
everything that you would have to know
for the SAT or the a CTE or or or take
the GED and the idea is to kind of give
and the problems were randomly generated
so if it takes you 500 problems to
understand negative exponents you're
gonna get 500 problems and in the
process it's tracking everything you do
it knows when you're and the videos are
coupled into it so if you get a problem
if you know how to do it you can you can
type in the answer if you don't know how
to do it you can click hints it'll give
you the steps for that exact problem if
you still don't know how to do it you
can click video and the video from
YouTube will pipe in so what I kind of
envision doing is closing the loop
between instruction
practice and assessment and making them
all happen simultaneously as opposed to
the traditional model where I lecture to
you I give you homework which you do in
a complete vacuum without any feedback
because the textbooks aren't giving you
any feedback and you may or may not know
how to do it and then we kind of keep
going in that cycle for a week or two
and then I give you an exam you get a C
so you clearly have some deficiencies
but too bad we have to move on to the
next concept so the model here is just
close the loop and and don't let anyone
have any deficiencies before they move
on so is it also the case that you're
starting to get telemetry that's telling
you something about the videos how
they're being used and what the before
and after comparison is the software
integration I've done it pretty heavily
with a couple of summer camps out here
in the Bay Area and and it's I haven't I
haven't gotten to the point yet where
I'm you know I'm testing two videos on
the same concept I don't have a lot of
you know multiple videos for the same
concept yet so I so I'm tweaking on that
level but yeah we have seen we did it
with a group of rising eighth graders
these were low and middle income mainly
minority students and this was a summer
program to get them prepared for algebra
and pre-algebra and we saw it when we
started the students at one plus one
equals two there was just some subset of
students who had just very very basic
deficiencies subtracting decimals or
multiplying negative numbers and and and
and you can see it in the data that they
spent a little bit more time on those
concepts and everyone else in the class
everyone else thought it was just a
review but these students it was a gap
but once they got through that gap they
raced forward and they were just as good
as anybody else and I think that speaks
to why there's a lot of if you go to an
algebra class didn't they did a lot of
great teachers with high potential
students talking past each other because
the teacher can't address the the
arithmetic issue and the teach and the
student may not even know they have that
deficiency or even if they do they're
they're embarrassed to bring it up so so
when you allow people to kind of do this
at their own pace you do see it in the
data that that it's actually hard to
predict who's going to end up at
different points because if you give
someone a time to film the fill in their
gaps you might have thought that they
were slow student before but what's that
gap is filled they actually progressed
quite fast it seems on the
and unimaginable that we could be here
in the 21st century and not have widely
available tools online already for
people to do those kinds of things to do
those kinds of your mediations but on
the other hand I guess it seemed kind of
unimaginable that millions of people
would be driving past this freeway
intersection nobody bothered to tell
them where North five points you know
you know the free you know the the the
freeway intersection that that one's
actually that one's uh that one's in the
education context there's some obvious
forces as to why that's not that that
doesn't exist today obviously I think
everyone who's trying to innovate in
education is trying to do it within the
current context so they're trying to go
into school systems and try to
incrementally change what teachers are
doing one way or the other so it's it's
it's very hard to kind of move the beast
so to speak and then and then you have
all these people on the for-profit realm
and I don't know they're just trying to
sell something for 1995 a month and I
don't think they're they're thinking too
deeply about how to do it right guard
list of economic consequences no you're
right it I think it almost has to come
from the outside and I don't know if you
know Graham glass he's a friend of mine
and he's working on a service called edu
2.0 yeah yeah you might be you might be
curious about that his um he's coming at
it from you know partly from a
courseware perspective but also from
very much from a project-based learning
perspective where the notion is so it's
kind of like this right you know I could
have in my school I could have a kid
who's interested in I don't know you
know making and flying rockets and there
might or might not be somebody in the
school who could mentor the kid and if
there is then you have one of those
lucky circumstances where the guy's a
great experience and if not you know
that that that capability goes on
untappd in the kid but on the internet
we have the possibility to to bring
people together across time and space
right so right you know you have the
possibility of bringing a mentor in from
someplace else
and you know assembling mentors and and
students in that way and and and letting
them actually then you know pursue the
stuff that excites them and do things
and so that's a nice kind of
complementary model but again I mean
it's you know he's coming completely
from the outside and I think that's
that's probably where all the
interesting action is going to be it's
gonna have to be right no I I agree yeah
I think I think that's where it's all
going I think you have you know you have
something like the Khan Academy has
video content it's gonna have software
it's gonna do analytics on on what's
working for a different students and
where different students are but then
you overlay that with kind of a peer to
peer interaction like like you just
described where the software knows that
for Sal the videos haven't been enough
and and even the software he's
struggling with it so why does let me
schedule and I know his schedule and I
know a schedule of a a young woman in in
I don't know in Mexico City who who's
proven through the through the through
the the site that she knows what she's
doing and she's a highly regarded tutor
maybe she might be the same age of sal
or a little older or maybe a practicing
engineer or who knows what and and you
pair them up and then you end but then
you capture you could even record the
interaction and then you capture the
data the before the after of sales
performance and his ratings and then all
of a sudden you have a very a rich kind
of peer-to-peer across time and space
interactions amongst amongst people all
over and obviously that has other other
implications beyond just you know
teaching people math it can it could do
a lot in terms of just awareness yeah
another another guy I should mention
here is Tim Fahlberg who's a math
teacher and he got interested in in
making well he called he actually has a
according to term for these things math
casts and he's been he's been doing them
with Camtasia for a long time and one of
the great things that he told me about a
project where they were working with I
think it was elementary school kids in
Australia is that he wound up having
those kids make educational videos for
each other yeah right and so that they
got to you know be the teacher and in
the process of teaching as you do when
you teach they also learned really well
and so they have they have a nice little
collection of these
problem-solving videos made by you know
4th graders and in Perth or Sydney or
somewhere massive on a massive scale and
you know even even if you have a
thousand versions of you know adding
negative numbers from a thousand
students I think as you said just just
them going through the motions of doing
it they're gonna get a lot deeper
understanding but but even better that
there's I mean even I like to review
some of my own I mean it what's better
than notes it's it's you're your own
recording of how you thought about it
two months ago when you were really
deeply and engaged in it so you have
that aspect and and then you have the
aspect you might be able to identify the
next you know the next great teacher
that way as well
exactly exactly and I'll you know I'll
throw this out I I think I think great
teachers were great when they were 13
I think much happens between 13 and 30
yeah I think that's true and you know in
the in the Bill Gates TED talk that I
that I just watched they said something
similar which is that you know there you
know that actually teachers in their
first couple of years go through an
experience curve but after that they're
they're pretty much where they're going
to be you know in the traditional school
system though that experience curve is
all around classroom management you know
I've talked to some of my friends or
teachers and they're like well you know
you don't have to do this the trouble on
is true I don't have to do any of that
and as I think that's where a lot of the
experience curve is more than I mean
there is you know okay it's you're
teaching to 30 or 25 kids so it's a
different concept and but but I think
just being able to explain and in a kind
of a patient and empathetic way what
what you know on YouTube I think that's
something that you know once once you
have a little bit of maturity you'll
probably be able to do as good as you'll
ever be able to do it yeah so have you
gotten into areas where you are teaching
yourself things that you hadn't
previously known are known well oh yeah
tons of I mean that frankly that's
that's the real fun for me is that I get
to revisit some things that you know I
just kind of did fairly superficially
when I was in school and now I get to
really dive deep in a on my own
timeframe without any pressure and
really get to understand what those
concepts are I'm the one example I was
giving this entropy I wasn't a chemistry
jock in high school I just kind of did
what
to do well in the class but I didn't
know it intuitively the way I might have
known in math or computer science so you
know that's been a great experience for
me I started in September and I really
just for two months I just became a
chemistry geek and I would call up my
friends or professors at Stanford and
MIT and say hey let's talk about entropy
and it's amazing I mean I think the one
one point of feedback I got from them is
they envied me because never and there
when they were doing their PhDs they
they couldn't go to their advisor and
say let's talk about entropy because
that's something that that you were
supposed to have known when you when you
took ap chemistry or freshman level of
chemistry but but the reality is very
few people do have an intuition of say
entropy including some professors today
and so I was you know actually entropy Z
examples I once I was able to kind of
get the idea to distilled in my mind I
realized that most explanations out
there were on some level wrong hmm in
what way well you know I'll you know the
way you learn in chemistry class your
teacher says entropy is disorder and
which isn't incorrect but they say a
clean room has low entropy and a dirty
room has high entropy and so you know
you've got the exact exam they say okay
this room is dirty this room is clean
which one has higher entropy and you
just kind of write it down and that's
wrong it's it's the it's missing the
whole point of what entropy is it took
me a while like to kind of distill this
idea is that when in in in chemistry or
in thermodynamics you you have macro
states and microstates microstates are
you're looking at a particular atom and
you're looking at its kinetic energy
you're looking at its momentum you're
looking at you know the vector of its
velocity and and if you looked at the
microstate of every little atom in a
container you could run a computer
simulation and then maybe you might
figure out what might happen the very
next moment and those are microstates
macro states are you look at the whole
container and and you you you describe
all of the particles you kind of almost
you can think of statistics for all of
the particles so temperature is a macro
state it's the average kinetic energy
for all of the particles and so entropy
similarly is a macro state but it's
almost a meta macro state it's it's this
idea
what state are the particles in its how
many potential states can the particles
have so in the messy clean room analogy
the reason why I say that's wrong is
because each of those are particular
states it doesn't say a messy room if
it's you know it depends on what level
you're thinking about it states but it
has the same number of you know because
of its temperature and its atoms have
the same number of potential states as
the clean room if a I guess I'll give
you a a really hot a clean room with
things flying around in the air is is is
going to be have higher entropy than a
than a cold dirty room with different
things hearts like here and here so it's
it's the number of states that that
something could have and you can even
translate that into computer science
it's the amount of information you need
to describe the state of a system so
something that can have more states you
need to have more bits to describe its
particular state and that's completely
lost at least it was in the chemistry
classes I took hmm that's good that's
good I bet one of the one of the other
areas that's going to be very fruitful
for you in coming years is energy
literacy okay you know these are
questions that I I you know I I got a
lot of a lot of people requests you know
a lot of clean tech lectures a lot of
people want me to kind of settle the
global warming debate the healthcare
debate and you know these are things
that I look forward to eventually I
don't know if I'm gonna be able to catch
up with the kind of the news cycle but
but IIIi think there is an opportunity
where I can dig deep into things and as
objectively as possible I think people
trust me because they learned calculus
from me that I'm not I don't have a
political kind of axe to grind and I can
give them a fairly objective hopefully
objective a take on things well when I
say energy literacy I'm talking about I
mean so to give you an example I was
looking at some of your stuff the other
day and I've also been recently I've
been hanging around on WolframAlpha a
lot because it's a really helpful way of
making conversions between units and
different forms of energy and matter and
so on and I and understanding you know
like like you'll sit you'll say I don't
know I put in my electric bill was
such-and-such kilowatt-hours it was like
1,200 kilowatt hours right like what is
that right what does that really mean
you know and it'll give it to you in
terms of gasoline that's cool you know
as a society we are broadly speaking
feeling like we need to have a better
handle on what does this stuff really
mean in terms that we can freely
interconvert and we're not so good at
that but you know I went from one of
your examples back to Wolfram Alpha and
was thinking it was I guess it was just
the you know the the elevator that
weighs so much and is you know 100
meters off the ground and it's got this
much potential energy and this much
kinetic energy when it hits the floor
and I looked at that relative to gallons
of gasoline and kilowatt hours of my
electric bill it was like wow you know I
wouldn't have thought this but
apparently like you know the energy I
burn as electricity in my home in a day
could take an elevator to the top of the
Empire State Building 10 or 20 times I
would I wouldn't have thought that right
and then I mean that's that's something
and it gives people a context for what
yeah what a kilowatt hour is what a what
a what a calorie is what a yeah what a
kill you know and any of the above yeah
cuz we really do we really lack those
intuitions it kind of struck me because
I wrote about this on my blog and I
realized you know all my life I've
thought about electric bills as dollars
and I mentioned something about well
this is my electric bill is this many
kilowatt hours and people wrote in from
Belgium and and the Netherlands and they
said really and what made me surprised
was that I suddenly realized you know
what they have an intuition about what
it means to be a quantity of kilowatt
hours right they don't it's like it's
not the first order for them isn't isn't
dollars or or euros
it's kilowatt hours that actually means
something to them in a way it doesn't it
to us right now I don't know I thought
that well that's you're inspiring me to
do a plug at least a couple of videos on
yeah yeah well listen I you know I think
I should let you get back to this this
stuff that you do and I don't really
have a lot else to to ask you but I just
you know I want to thank you for for for
what you're doing I think
brilliant and I I'm happy to see it
happening I'm happy for you two to be
excited and enjoying doing this and I
know that you're gonna find a way to
make this work out as a as a profession
as a career as a as a you know a
lifetime mission oh great I appreciate I
have that gut feeling I miss being done
as a not-for-profit but yeah we need to
get to the point that uh
the not-for-profit can convey my rents
yeah there's no way that there's no way
in my mind there's no way that can't
happen but yeah I'm getting that gut
feeling hopefully you'll hear some
interesting news from us in the well I
don't want to jinx us but we'll see okay
well thanks a lot sell thanks Lodge on
you've been listening to interviews with
innovators with hosts jon udell
our audio files are delivered by
limelight networks the high performance
content delivery network for digital
media the conversations network is a
501c3 nonprofit and we need your help
for a tax-deductible donation of as
little as five dollars per month you can
support this channel and the rest of the
conversations network so please visit
conversations network org to become a
member and help us continue to bring our
programs to the world for free the
post-production audio engineer for this
program was Jon Udell our website editor
was Joel journey the series producer is
Joel journey this is Phil Wendy I hope
you'll join me next time for another
great edition of interviews with
innovators on IT conversations